[Musique]
morse elle a quitté l'afghanistan à neuf
mois en 1993 l'année de l'émergence du
mouvement taliban
[Musique]
femme
son père était fonctionnaire il a fuit
le pays en premier sa famille a suivi
une semaine après un voyage de tous les
dangers il pouvait s'arrêter mamère
premièrement mars inc vraie belle femme
qu'il pouvait prendre m après les stats
fille qui venait avec elle ça c'était le
plus gros danger et jusqu'à maintenant
on sait on se sent tellement tellement
chanceuse morcelle est finalement arrivé
au canada en 2003 ma mère me dit souvent
qu'à kaboul c'était le pari
d'afghanistan en 2018 il a enfin pu
retourner dans son pays d'origine ça ça
m'avait vraiment donner l'espoir j'ai
dit oh mon dieu ça change je voyais des
femmes à conduire je voyais les femmes
de milliards des avocats je voyais les
femmes en tant que
artistes s'exprimer il n'y avait pas une
une seule chose que je me sentis en
danger la situation pendant 20 ans avait
laissé un espoir pour les fillettes et
pour les femmes de pouvoir aller à
l'école de pouvoir étudier de pouvoir
travailler de pouvoir présenter un
journal télévisé sans même être être
voilées il ya fort à craindre que
l'évolution soit inverse
[Musique]
en afghanistan cet ancien fonctionnaire
vie déjà sous le règne de la terreur
avant la prise de kaboul il dirigeait
une équipe de 70 femmes au ministère de
l'intérieur
groupe elle a reçu une lettre de menaces
alors pour sortir zaknoun se couvre de
la tête aux pieds wickens blick
la burqa les touffes
mais il n'a pas le choix toutes ces
photos sont sur facebook et les talibans
déjà mis la main sur ces données
personnelles dans le serveur du
ministère
elle est aussi une hasard à une
minorités religieuses persécutées et là
toutes les raisons d'avoir peur
[Musique]
d un mari one gueule
plutôt mourir que d'être mariées de
force un taliban dit elle
dans les campagnes les femmes afghanes
souffrent davantage
les avancées ont surtout concerné des
zones urbaines ou dippach tana d'oranie
qui milite pour la scolarisation des
filles depuis l'âge de 7 ans
l'année dernière elle a reçu un
financement de la fondation mal à la
vache tana est très sceptique quand elle
voit comment les manifestations sont
réprimées
elle veut des actes et non des paroles
ni pat shanhan isaf ne veulent quitter
l'afghanistan
acheter un aveu que les leaders
occidentaux fasse pression sur les
talibans
afghans continuent de motiver ses
troupes et de croire en un avenir
possible pour les femmes afghanes au
québec des organismes se mobilisent pour
les aider on est bien positionné pour
rayon des fils légende admissible pour
la liste des des réfugiés qui vont venir
ici surtout on et focus et sur les
femmes et sur les enfants
mais à voir le chaos à l'aéroport de
kaboul et les barrages des talibans
tout pousse à croire qu'il leur sera
difficile de quitter le pays ici à sucre
hayat radio canada montréal